normally on trans day of visibility I
would be doing something join us
going look how happy I am
to be out and to be trans and don't get
me wrong I'm
still very happy to be me but
it's hard to be joyous right now
we live in a time where being visibly
trans is
more dangerous than it has been at any
time in my memory certainly
and being visible makes you the target
of multiple hate groups and currently an
entire political party
in some countries
but
even if you yourself
either cannot or or not yet ready to be
visible
I will still make myself visible
because you need to know you're not
alone
with everything else going on
visibility matters all the more for
those of us who can do it